thank you Mark and what I think
everybody can hear me okay can't can't
you without the microphone okay and I
appreciate everybody for coming out
tonight and thank you for Yale for
hosting me I had a very engaging day so
far today with faculty and students and
I'm impressed at the level of enthusiasm
in knowledge base I don't know why I
should be impressed at that at Yale but
with everybody keeping up with all
aspects of this story and I've been
studying it full time for years now and
I'm always learning so I appreciate
again the opportunity to visit here i'm
going to give an overview of some of the
political and social dynamics that I
have learned as a reporter at the press
& sun-bulletin that's right on the
border of pennsylvania's in southern
tier of New York covering this and some
of the impacts on people as I have
written about this over the years but
first I'm going to be right up front
because people ask me about my views on
high-volume hydraulic fracturing and
whether I'm for it or whether I'm
against it or whether I think it's a
good idea or a bad idea and I'll be up
front and saying that I have no public
opinion on that I have not I'm not going
to make a judgment based on the risks
and the rewards of high-volume hydraulic
fracturing but I do have a public
opinion on this and that is transparency
there's a journalist I'm all about full
disclosure in full transparency now my
stories with the press & sun-bulletin
are often sympathetic to people that get
the raw end of the deal whether their
land owners or people who are they
they're looking for information that
they can't get i have i guess i would
tell you somewhat of a liberal view of
the traditional liberal view of the
press that is the press is an agent for
social change
and in Pulitzer is to purify joseph
poachers ideals is comfort the afflicted
afflict the comfortable give a voice to
the voiceless look it suspiciously and
skeptically it concentrations of wealth
and power and rake the mock so that is
kind of an old school principal pre Fox
News and Joseph principal Joseph
Pulitzer a course was back in the Gilded
Age the days before Union the days when
there's a big division of class and
that's kind of how the press has
operated for a long time so that often
makes me antagonistic to companies or
sometimes it puts me on the same side of
the fence as the anti-fracking activists
who are looking for information but I
have not closed my mind to the idea that
corporations do it can and often do work
in good public faith good public
consciousness and obviously free
corporate enterprise is a huge important
part of our freedom now with that out of
the way I'm going to just briefly go
over just a few things that probably
most people are familiar with already so
I'm not going to spend much time thank
you this is the footprint of the
Marcellus Shale and one reason this is
such a big story is that this is a big
carbon reserve a world-class carbon
reserve that is now accessible in a part
of the world where it never was
previously and it covers a huge area of
four states and then this is the
drilling fairway the high probability
drilling fairway this is the area where
the prospects are most promising for
development and ness in the area
extending down from West Virginia going
up through the capsicum region of New
York this
is the Utica Shale which is underneath
the Marcellus it covers an even larger
footprint and this is respect the source
for a lot of the resources that you're
seeing coming out of Ohio now it's
relatively unexplored in upstate New
York and in Pennsylvania but it's an
important aspect of the story because
there's not only one carbon reserves
there's two and in some areas when you
combine these with conventional
conventional reserves then you have
something called stacked horizons and
this makes it especially especially
promising for a company that is
exploring because they can tap one
resource while one horizon while
exploring others now here's an example
of stacked horizons in upstate New York
and as you can see they're both
conventional and unconventional
resources underneath here now you
probably have been following the story
you know that drilling is well off and
underway in Pennsylvania where there's
about 10,000 Marcellus Shale wells
unconventional shale wells that are
drilled or have been permitted and in
New York State nothing at all has
happened so how did we get here how did
we they both share the same geology or
similar geology they both sit over the
same valuable resource how did we get to
a point where one state is actively
producing it and the other state nothing
has happened and this has a lot to do
with the politics it has to do a lot
with the perception and I'm going to
take you back to the beginning of the
shale gas rush in the Marcellus area
which was 2006-2007 that happened very
quietly the mainstream media certainly
wasn't paying attention range resources
were developing wells in southwestern
Pennsylvania and keeping the information
relatively perp I proprietary and in
2000
in seven Cabot Oil & Gas also started
drilling some wells in northeastern
Pennsylvania and some other companies
got onto the play and it started
meanwhile another very important fact by
fact in this is the price of natural gas
was climbing this was a big incentive
for more aggressive exploration in
development and again I'm not going to
go too far into the the difference
between the conventional and
unconventional plays but it made the
economics of exploring and perfecting
the high-volume slickwater frack more
viable because drilling and
unconventional well is a fairly capital
intensive and risky concern it's less
risky now is more come online and they
developed the technology the back in
2006 2007 2008 it was they've
essentially able to use a lot of the
technology that was pioneered down in
Texas in the Barnett Shale and transpose
it to the scenarios up in up in the
Marcellus in the Appalachian region so
we're back to the question about why did
things start taking off in Pennsylvania
and why not in in New York well they did
start to take off in New York in 2008
with land prospecting and this is when
people were realizing that they could
they could develop an unconventional
well with good success in Pennsylvania
and the price of natural gas was high so
they started leasing up land and the
land leases came to South the southern
tier of New York and they got together
some farmers were they formed a
coalition because there's a lot of land
mend at the door and the coalition was
intended to try to leverage bargaining
power with with a landman and we didn't
know much about this at the newspaper
this was all going on it was under
reported until I did know some of the
farmers farmers came in in one day a
group of these farmers least 50,000
acres one of these coalition's at least
50,000 acres with the company called XTO
energy that's now owned by ExxonMobil
for 110 million dollars now these
farmers many of them almost all of them
made more in that one deal than they
would see in a lifetime and everybody
started paying very close attention this
became it was just before this happened
our natural gas development was one of
many stories I was covering after this
happened it became this story everybody
was very excited about shale gas they
saw it is clean energy national
independence and economic driver there
was nothing there was nothing not to
like about shale gas development now
there was also a lot of questions though
that people brought up this was I will
mention two years before josh fox made
fracking a bad word so what happened
okay we have the June of 22 thousand and
eight everybody's excited about a 110
million dollar deal but everybody was
asking questions and these questions
arose not with an anti-fracking movement
but with the townsfolk's with Public
Safety workers with zoning people they
wanted to know what would transportation
people with roads and highway p police
would be on a different scale suddenly
they knew it was different from the
conventional types of gas drilling they
had seen and they wanted answers so they
went to the Department of Environmental
Conservation or more precisely the
Department of Environmental Conservation
came to them that's the state agency
regulatory agency in New York to try to
answer these questions and i'm going to
read an excerpt from my book here under
the surface that just characterizes the
scene and what i think was a pivotal
moment in the New York's history in
terms of is energy policy
and it started at a town hall meeting
and the meeting was with Linda caller a
representative of the Dec and several
other people a member of the Farm Bureau
and some other people that were on the
panel that would try to answer questions
they sat in front of several hundred
residents suburban Knights farmers and
officials from the town county and state
governments who packed the public hall
beyond capacity the meeting was also
streamed online caller Tran through a
PowerPoint presentation of how merciless
development would proceed using
information in photographs from
conventional plays in upstate New York
she paused on a slide showing a lush
meadow of wildflowers and grasses with a
bank of trees in the background this was
a reclaimed natural gas site she said in
an example of the expected long-term
impact from Marcellus development I
recognized the slide from a Dec
displayed two years earlier when I was
covering public hearings on a proposal
by the office of mineral resources to
lease the mineral rights of state
forests in the southern tier in central
New York Marcellus prospect during had
yet to become a public phenomenon and
there had been no mention of shale gas
at those meetings nonetheless prospects
of any kind of drilling on state land
drew fierce opposition from outdoor
enthusiasts ranging from hunters two
hikers at these hearings jock Jack doll
director of the Dec Bureau of oil and
gas regulation set up a display with the
colleagues with his colleagues pitching
clean well-organized drill sites
including before and after landscape
depictions the display had included the
photograph the collared now showed and
doll had given a similar assessment that
the impact from gas development due to
the quote well-established regulatory
program end quote and quote rigorous
permitting process and quote of the
agency would be minimal or even
environmentally beneficial over the long
term the crowd at the Chenango town hall
was skeptical people fired questions at
the panel before college presentation
was over a person in back stood up and
asked how local emergency responders
could prepare for a spill fire explosion
when the industry did not fully disc
the complete chemical content and
concentrations of fracking fluids
colored colored looked at the other
members of the panel to see if they
might want to take a crack at that one
they looked back at her expectantly we
don't anticipate any significant
emergencies she said after a pause these
things are rare another person stood up
and asked how regulators were prepared
for an influx of drilling that would
exceed any historical comparison call it
responded we've been doing fine so far
no problems she returned to her
powerpoint and was interrupted again by
a person who noted that incentives for
roadside dumping would go up is waste
increase faster than the options for
treatment how would the agency handle
that you have land owners out there you
have neighbors out there we would hear
about it collared said hopefully the
operators will be responsible more
questioning along the same lines
followed her presentation and she
delivered the same answers flow back is
classified as an industrial waste and
therefore requires a permit for
transport she said again and again came
a question where does it go I can't
answer that she said it's all regulated
she added so this was the type of
response for the record that the Dec was
giving to residents and residents became
skeptical again these were not
anti-fracking activists there were
people looking for answers and I think
this illustrates the attitudes and the
level of preparedness of the regulatory
agency in New York at that time which
was essentially nil now as I said I was
working for the paper I was covering
this and other similar meetings and
after this particular meeting caller was
on the record it was streamed online a
lot of these reports her comments as
quoted here were reported in the
newspaper and the next day I got a call
from the governor's office saying that
the next meeting because they're having
these meetings on a weekly basis
throughout the area where we're leases
that had been leased up on the next
meeting that some of the Dec top
officials
not just the mid-level bureaucracy but
the top officials would be down to
address the problem and the long story
short Judith enck who was governor's top
administrator and environmental advisor
at the time came to the next meeting and
Judith enck is a like long career
activist she had worked at in new york
state public research interest group and
other things before she got in politics
in other words she came up through she
didn't come up through the rank-and-file
Dec she was an activist and a political
appointee she came to the next meeting
and it was a packed auditorium in
another town and this she addressed
similar questions and her answers were
these are really good questions we're
glad you're asked you should hold our
feet to the fire we will get good
answers within two weeks after that the
Pattersons administration issued a
moratorium wasn't technically a
moratorium it was just saying we won't
issue permits on this until we have done
a full environmental review that
environmental review was supposed to
take a year it ended up taking another
year now Josh Fox's movie came out the
anti activist establishment gained a
foothold and they essentially made New
York the centerpiece of anti-fracking
the anti-fracking movement now there's
one other very important element here
and it goes back I'll just go back to
oops this slide here you can see the
Catskills of New York you can't see it
real well but up and around here is then
is the Delaware River Basin and several
reservoirs that feed New York City's
watershed and this is one of the
desirable areas of drilling and at that
point people were very anxious about the
prospects of any type of gas extraction
from a watershed that feeds in New York
City this became a very political issue
and in subsequent drafts of this
environmental review they said that they
would not allow
in this watershed but that opened up all
sorts of issues well if it's not safe
enough for one watershed why is it safe
enough for another watershed it also
opened up issues of when you take off a
section regulate a section of land
privately owned land and say you can't
develop your exploit your mineral rights
people can say well what is the
government to tell me what I can and
can't do with my land this is called a
takings claim legal terms that the
government can't take away your rights
or if they can they can be challenged
for it
ok this is the slide I used to depict
before frac was a bad word and what
wasn't like about it there's still many
people who feel strongly about this of
course they again this gets the
polarizing point and we see this
obviously in the last presidential race
and debate one thing the two candidates
had in common is they both seemed to
very much like the extraction industry
not just natural gas and fracking
although Obama listed that as a priority
in his energy plan but all extraction in
terms of all energy the reality is we
need energy in we other countries
developing countries in particular need
energy even more than we do this is
actually the slide that Linda caller
used in her presentation to show what
shale gas development would look like
this is a conventional well in western
New York over the Trenton Black River
Formation so the DEP see our regulators
there were holding in that up as shale
gas development and it really showed
that they may have known that it looked
differently than this if they did they
weren't letting on or maybe they just
didn't know now this takes us to
Pennsylvania and Pennsylvania the
cultural differences of Pennsylvania are
tied in with the history and legacy of
the extraction industry and I bring up
Pennsylvania because throughout the book
and throughout actually this national
debate debate the theme is that there's
this polarization and Pennsylvania is
really a state that represents the state
that went ahead and said this is good we
need to do it although obviously with in
Pennsylvania there's debate as there is
within New York but New York is it
exemplifies I think the state that says
we can't do this is too risky
the history in Pennsylvania is a land
exploitation long mining mining legacy
obviously the anthracite coal mines in
Pennsylvania the modern petroleum
industry was founded in Pennsylvania in
the mid-1800s with the Drake oil fields
in western Pennsylvania there's a long
legacy there quarrying timbering
obviously the tolerance level and the
expectations of living in with the
extraction industry in Pennsylvania is
more like it is in Texas whereas people
have been around it for a long time this
is the Knox mining disaster when mining
company went to close to the the basin
of the Susquehanna River it broke
through the water poured into the mine
shafts and 12 miners died I guess I
raised this is just the one of the
examples of the risks of the extraction
industry that people live with I mean
mining is hard difficult business but
it's also the industry on which the
Industrial Revolution was built I mean
we could go on about the mining in coal
you have centralia centralia where you
still have a fire burning underneath the
town the town was abandoned because of
the coal seam fire there's a legacy in
other words there's acid mind discharge
but this is the price of a lot of the
modern conveniences that we now take for
granted and I think that one thing that
really has struck me with all this is we
love the conveniences that the
extraction industry affords us or has
afforded us and our and our ancestors
flip on a switch fire update the gas
fire up the heat all these things are
wonderful as long as we don't have to
look at it too closely and in New York
State certainly in a lot of other states
we haven't had
to look at it too closely but now with
the shale gas industry covering such a
large geographical area in the Northeast
and other areas we're really forced to
take a good hard look and I think that's
important here's the Drake oil fields
back in the mid 1800s in western
Pennsylvania now I think that was a time
before cumulative impact I think that's
the word that you hear in a lot of
policy documents now I don't think they
knew about cumulative impact back in the
Drakkar at least they didn't articulate
it that way they weren't too concerned
about it okay now so I told you about
the turning point in New York where the
political wheels started turning to keep
shale gas out of New York I'm going to
read you another part about what
happened in Pennsylvania when people
started to realize that maybe this shale
gas development was different in the
first instances when people started
realizing perhaps the long-term
implications now it's important to know
that and I'm going to talk about them in
just a few minutes the the folks in in
Pennsylvania that least their land were
generally enthusiastic about it I guess
they wouldn't have released at least
their land if they weren't but some
least their land at twenty-five dollars
an acre and then they heard the news
that right across the border in New York
that group of coalition of farmers were
leasing it for 300 3,500 dollars an acre
four thousand dollars an acre or more
all right so they were saying geez we
really missed the boat on that one we
got taken advantage of but they were
still hopeful they were hopeful that
their wells would produce and they would
get royalty payments and endemic
Pennsylvania the place where i was
looking is a mixed demographic but
there's a lot of poverty there and a
very set of characters that I talk about
in the book that are impacted in various
ways
but I'm going to read you this quick
excerpt that is that is a turning point
there and this is from the perspective
of pet for Nellie who's on Carter Road
from the laundry line in her side yard
petronelli had a sweeping view of the
scene that would determine her future
man in the equipment had moved from the
hill across the Burdick Creek hollow to
a fellow pasture directly below the
house in late-september 2008 bulldozers
cut through a field ablaze with
goldenrod to level a pad for guests
furred 3 the well would draw gas from
under the adjoining farinelli land and
the family's mortgage depended on
corresponding royalties the derrick went
up in our early October and soon the
platform straddling the hole was busy
with men and coveralls and hard hats who
are lifting swinging in lowering pipes
with hydraulics and heavy hardware
hanging from chains shouts of men over
machinery and generators carried up the
valley sometimes with the smell of heavy
machinery and diesel exhaust as work
progressed it was easy for pet to
believe destiny was working in her favor
at schools churches in the lockout lunch
counter and gas Mart the news of landman
and their promises was giving away to
the excitement of wells producing
millions of cubic feet per day from the
teal and Ely properties there was also
news of corresponding royalties crews
were now busy building compressor
stations and pipelines on the teal land
at fair compensation she heard and
drilling other wells along Carter well
our Carter Road this is what Cabot's
eight six hundred million dollars in
shale gas development looked like the
size and intensity the operation its
manic focus and energy were all directed
at producing wealth and Pat to comfort
in knowing her twenty acres were locked
into the equation even a drop of that
wealth three thousand dollars or four
thousand dollars per month would make
things good for them they could pay
their mortgage by horses or other
animals and make a go at farming her
oldest daughter was getting married that
spring and they would have enough for a
nice wedding Pat would no longer have to
worry about making ends meet for six
dependent children when Social Security
food stamps and the lousy hours in low
pay Martin was getting at the flying j
diner that's where he worked as a
up the shouts from men in the drone of
diesel motors and generators on October
eighth 2008 a bright Wednesday morning
didn't sound peculiar dapat the crew had
drilled to 2,000 feet still several
thousand feet above the marcellus pay
zone when they encountered a problem
that brought the multimillion-dollar
operation to an inglorious stop the
breeze from the upper layers had fallen
into the hole in jam the drill the
devonian bedrock under gust 43 is
covered by 400 feet of glacial till
unconsolidated stone and gravel known in
the industry as overburden drilling
through the till is like trying to
trying to bore through a gravel pile and
although there are techniques to deal
with it they are not foolproof a drill
that jammed somewhere in the overburden
might have been less of a problem but
the guests furred crews had already
worked through the till and we're well
into the gas bearing zone of bedrock
above the Marcellus gas had begun
flowing and the crews left with an open
uncased hole had no way to control it
the problem persisted throughout the
fall to Pat it looked pretty much the
same from day to day with a
round-the-clock procession of equipment
in men the yelling at the site might
have been laced with a little more
profanity than usual she reflected in
hindsight but really there was no way
for to know for her to know the problem
would soon amount to more than a lost
piece of hardware DEP inspectors were
also ignorant of complications of guests
43 until an event on New Year's Day 2009
put them on notice a blast echoed
through the hills a mile north of the
guests furred well concrete dust
billowed from the ground and hung in the
frigid air over the ruins of Norma
fiorentino as well normal was having
supper at her daughter Brenda's home
with her daughter grandchildren and
great grandchild she was feeling
optimistic that this year would be
better than the last Brenda's chemo
treatments for keeping the cancer in
checked and her granddaughter was
expecting a second child with luck she
would could buy some nice baby things
with royalty payments now upon her
return home she said trying to she stood
trying to fathom the gaping hole and the
shattered remains of a massive concrete
slab cover
bring her well a random act of violence
who would want to blow up her well she
called 911 veiled Volunteer Fire
Department cord as the Springfield
Volunteer Fire Department cordon off
Norma's yard with bright yellow caution
tape cabot representatives arrived on
the scene they took some tests around
her house and determined that any gas if
it was there was not lingering and
that's what Norma's well looked like
although Norma's well was soon to become
famous it was neither the first nor the
worst case of methane migration related
to gas drilling in Pennsylvania or
elsewhere much of what officials knew
about the danger of a methane migration
they had learned years before from worst
costly instances the Pennsylvania DEP
bureau of oil and gas management had
filed files on more than 50 other cases
dating from the beginning of 2004 the
time Nora fiorentino is well exploded
all involved dangerous and sometimes
fatal accumulations of gas migrating
from new or abandoned wells into a
closed spaces they had happened before
the shale gas rush became big news and
they gained relatively little attention
in 2002 for dep records demonstrated the
collection of gas in the basement of the
harbor residents near several wells
being drilled by the Snyder brothers in
Jefferson County about 80 miles
northeast of Pittsburgh on march 5th the
furnace kicked on in an explosion
leveled the house and killed Charles
Harper his wife Dorothy and their son
Bailey grandson Bailey report by the
Pittsburgh Geological Society includes a
photograph of the scene a foundation
covered by charred rubble and the shells
have burnt out automobiles in the
driveway and this is a quote from that
report although it rarely makes
headlines damage or threats caused by
gas migration is a common problem in
western Pennsylvania in July 2008 an
explosion killed the resident of Marion
County who tried to light a candle in
the bathroom the DEP record of the event
one paragraph long
it's the agency quote-unquote became
aware of the problem after the fatality
which it linked to gas migrating into
the septic system from an old gas well
with deteriorating casing the dep files
also contain some cases noteworthy for
what was unknown or at least
undocumented and this is right from the
file unknown name Armstrong County
Southwest Regional Office 1999 house
explosion resulting in destruction of
residents and one fatality investigation
is not well documented mechanism of
migration is an operating gas well
pressurized pressurization of casing
status resolved so here's the the report
that talks about the various migrations
from the DEP here's the photograph it
doesn't really translate very well here
of the Pittsburgh geological society now
methane migration I bring this up and I
just wanted to make a point of this
lecture because we see we talked about
josh fox and the flaming faucet in all
the issues related to hydraulic
fracturing that he brings up in his
perspective but i think people are
probably might know this already but the
issues related to my methane migration
aren't really specifically a fracking
issue even though josh fox and the
flaming faucet he portrays it as such
methane migration is a complicated thing
and it's not necessarily just related to
it's not necessarily related to fracking
at all maybe or maybe not it definitely
is more related to drilling gas drilling
certainly but it could be related to
drilling a water well it could be
related to it could just happen by
itself in other words you have these
methane seeps and petroleum seeps in the
ground some are deep some are shallow in
areas where you have a lot of carbon
reserves a lot of petroleum reserves and
a lot of gas reserves you have a lot
more methane in the ground sometimes in
concentrations sometimes in the industry
would like to say this this gas gets
into water wells by itself and this is
true
so it gets to be a very confusion
confusing thing because if anybody of
you any of you have seen truth land you
will see instances where people have
testified that they could always light
their water on fire and we hear the
industry say that there's two generally
types of methane now I'm not a geologist
and we have several geologists in the
audience so I please flag me if I go too
far afield here but I'm going to talk
about bio biogenic methane and
thermogenic methane and this is one of
the test of the origins of methane and
whether methane in water wells where it
comes from biogenic methane is the kind
related to biological decomposition in
swamps and landfills thermogenic methane
sometimes called production gas is
created under heat and pressure in
bedrock so thermogenic methane if it
gets in the water is more generally
possibly a case of drilling especially
if there's been drilling into into
bedrock there's other more specific ways
technical ways that scientists can trace
methane to various layers but I guess
the whole issue of methane migration is
a very important issue in terms of the
political context of the debate because
people talk about the risks and they see
the flaming faucets and also the
technical aspects of the debate there's
some very knowledgeable people that
follow this very closely and they will
according to some of my sources they
will say yes people talk about the wrist
of fracking I'll talk more about that
and in a minute but really this methane
migration is an important risk and that
brings us to well casings and other
issues so just in the well casing debate
is long technical involved debate and a
long and short of it from my perspective
is ken casings effectively prevent
migration of you see when you drill a
hole in the ground obviously it's a
conduit for mapping to move up move up
and can they prevent can they block off
the water bearing zones effectively over
time
now so normal Fiorentina's well changed
the discussion in in Pennsylvania and
people started saying well jeez we
didn't know that Wells could blow up and
we had a lot of people starting to have
other water problems sometimes it's
turbidity sometimes it's ill-defined and
this is going to get to the transparency
part of it in a minute again as a
journalist I feel strongly about this is
very important for other companies to
say exactly what they're emitting they
have all sorts of standards if they're
emitting hazardous waste or releasing
hazardous waste they have to they have
to document that and do something about
it but the drilling industry is not so
because there's exceptions so it gets
very hard to understand to hold industry
accountable when the industry has
exemptions from these disclosure and we
will talk a little bit about the
Halliburton loophole that Halliburton
loophole is in the 2005 Energy Act and
it essentially exempts the drilling
industry from disclosing what they put
into the ground without this exemption
the drilling industry would come under
federal regulation and that would open
up a can of worms for the industry a
higher burden for it to operate back to
Pennsylvania in 2009 in normal
fiorentino as well residents with water
problems started getting together and a
lot of them I talked about in the book
they cut across different demographic
classes there's Norma fiorentino the
carters round and gene their second
generation farmers we're trying to save
for retirement and expected the
royalties would would help them retire
Victoria Schweitzer became actually a
fairly hope high-profile person she was
a retired schoolteacher in a newlywed
and she and her husband Jim were
building their contemporary dream home
when they least their land in seven
acres it was a big beautiful
than being home that they lost their
water couldn't drink their water and
there's drilling all around him so the
drilling boom really turned into
something much different than what she
expected she called themselves this
group accidental activists because a lot
of these people in Pennsylvania they
never had their name in the paper except
for a birth or maybe a marriage
announcement these were not people that
sought the limelight and they became at
least in New York and Pennsylvania in
the early days of the fracking issues
household names now there's other people
on the other side of the fence who came
to the defense of shale gas and they got
tired of hearing about all the problems
and because they thought that it was
unfair that people were focusing on the
problems and not necessarily the
benefits don lockhart lockhart lunch
counter who's right down in Pennsylvania
a local figure sells a lot of gas has a
lot of business and he says you know I'm
making money off this and I'm not afraid
to admit it because that's that's the
American Way what's wrong with that I
like Don have a lot of respect for him
Dewey Decker is the farmer in deposit
New York that had led the coalition that
landed the big deal with XTO energy for
110 million dollars and that's his farm
there and do he makes the very good
point that if we don't like shale gas
development here but we like our clean
energy or should say our abundant energy
are abundant cheap energy can we can we
like it when it happens over in another
country with environmental consequences
in political consequences possibly far
worse than what we're experiencing here
it's a point to think about
okay and then so we had the people of
the town board the municipal planners
and the public safety people in New York
and we had the accidental act activists
in Pennsylvania then we had josh fox
release his gas line that was in the
summer of 2010 and then we had a
national movement start which would
gained a lot of traction in New York
State a lot of it related to the new
york city water supply people cared very
passionately about that and it kind of
went national after that okay so where
do we go from here a couple critical
things the EPA water study this is
something that actually began with a
representative in the broom area
represented Ithaca Maurice hinchey he's
retiring this year and he was behind the
frack act and he also was on the
Appropriations Committee in Congress and
he helped fund an EPA study to take a
look at fracking's impact on groundwater
now the Halliburton loophole that we
talked about was predicated on a
previous study under the Bush
administration that looked at coal bed
methane and found that it did not impact
water supplies that that study was
criticized retro actively and people
said that it wasn't reviewed properly
and it was too narrow in scope and even
some former EPA people involved in it
said they never intended it as a policy
document although I don't know how the
EPA can put out something and not expect
it to be used as a policy so the
political wheels turned more eccentric
comes on the scene
there's political momentum to send the
EPA back or refund the EPA recommission
the current EPN under the Obama
administration to take a look at this
they've been doing this since 2010
Dimmick is one area they're looking at
and they're looking at other areas too
they're expected to have a progress
report on this in by the end of this
year the peer review this study is
supposed to be up for peer review in
2014 and you can that there'll be a huge
political influence because depending on
what it comes up with it could set some
initiative to repeal the Halliburton
loophole Meili is that possible don't oh
you know there's a lot of politics that
work there's a lot of science at work
and I like to say that policy is where
politics meat science and and I think
you'll have that equation coming
together here with this I mean as we see
the Obama administration has listed
shale gas development as a is a priority
in the energy future so will it be
regulated by the EPA I think is the
bigger question and if it is regulated
by the PPA what will that do for the
economic viability especially if prices
remain low gets us to the other next
important thing which are markets the
price is low now which is an incentive
to for coal coal plants to turn over to
natural gas and that's happening in a
lot of areas in Connecticut Governor
Malloy has recently talked about
initiatives to get a lot of the coal
fire plants on to natural gas cleaner
burning this is open to debate now but
certainly less particular matter less
mercury that's a big thing it's hard to
talk about natural gas development
without factoring in coal and this is a
personal struggle I have a little bit
when I'm thinking about cheat on what
would you do we know that renewables
right now in the in this global market
for carbon I'm sorry for
energy are not at a point where they can
really carry the load and especially
when you start factoring into the
developing countries so where are we
what what do we do conservation is
certainly important this is all
something I guess that we're going to
have to figure out over the next decade
or so how will climate change influence
this decision you have these competing
fossil fuels natural gas and coal versus
or the renewables okay and then I'm
going to just finish up here with this
idea of home rule this is also going to
influence the industry it's the idea
that states regulate natural gas
development now will the federal
government come into play with the
regulations will have to see it doesn't
you know it depends on the EPA study
depends on a lot of other things but
local municipalities are trying to
regulate the industry in New York and
Pennsylvania and they're saying we
should have some say in citing these
wells the industry should comply to
local zoning which it is exempt from
right now New York in fact has banned
the industry in dryden in middlefield
under using local zoning laws the
industry said you can't do that the
state has the authority over gas
drilling and you're preempted by by
state law and the municipality said oh
yes sir we can the industry took them to
court in lower court the municipalities
one and that is now going to appeal
similar in Pennsylvania a very similar
thing is happening and that's before the
state's highest court right now to see
whether the legislation which forbids or
limits municipal rule on shale gas is in
fact constitutional or not the industry
needs what it says is predictability and
conformity to develop a large gas play
so when you have
local municipalities opting out it can
it can influence that that's just in New
York at given time some of the
municipalities that we're considering
bands or some sort of regulation
okay i will be happy to take any
questions that you might have thank you